we're learning more about tomorrow
night's State of the Union address the
White House says the president Trump
will use the theme building a safe
strong and proud America senior White
House officials are promoting the idea
that the speech will be unifying it will
highlight the recent tax victory and lay
out ideas for trade immigration and
immigration reform and a 1.7 trillion
dollar plan to rebuild US infrastructure
major Garrett's at the White House
morning major good morning president
Trump speech will among other things
focus on immigration stock market
records low unemployment and tax cut
induced bonus checks it will come
against the backdrop of historically low
approval ratings then there's the Russia
investigation in steps mr. Trump took
last June to sideline it but first
president Trump in his own words on what
it's like to tweet at sunrise if I don't
have that form of communication I can't
defend myself the President and Twitter
provocateur said Sunday his tweets are
sometimes dictated or sent by advisers
but more often than not he is the author
sometimes in bed and for perhaps
sometimes at breakfast or lunch or
whatever but generally speaking during
the early morning or during the evening
I can do that mr. Trump has denounced
the Russia investigation on Twitter CBS
News has confirmed that last June the
president talked about firing special
counsel robert muller citing three areas
of possible conflict of interest last
week mr. Trump denied reports that he
ordered Muller's firing fake to his
folks fake news
Jessica New York I mistake stories
nothing mr. Trump said about rousting
Muller was ever relayed to the Justice
Department where the power to fire
Muller actually resides we know that if
he tried to it'd be the end of his
presidency South Carolina Republican
Lindsey Graham described the
consequences of dismissing Muller White
House Counsel Don Magan was frustrated
by the talk of firing Muller and also
other matters he threatened to resign
but not directly to mr. Trump top
advisors urged the president to leave
Muller alone McGann remains White House
Counsel and Muller is still special
counsel Don McGann if the story is true
in the new york times did the right
thing and the good news is the president
listened also the Trump Justice
Department reportedly believed that a
Trump campaign advisor Carter Page was
acting as a Russian agent according to a
report in The New York Times a memo
drafted in secret by House Republicans
reveals the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein extended surveillance of page
that memo which has yet to be released
publicly also alleges that warrant was
originally put together based on
research financed by Democrats John all
right major thank you CBS News we'll
bring you the State of the Union address
tomorrow night at 9:00 Eastern 8:00
central here on CBS Norah Gayle and I
will lead our coverage from New York
while Jeff Glor anchors from Washington
our entire political team will provide
reporting and analysis